We have to sort of accept something that for
a lot of Americans and people who live in
the United States may be sort of difficult
to accept.
I know there's people in the audience that
this will be a difficult realization to come
to.
The United States is rapidly losing superpower
status over what has been a disgustingly incompetent
response to the virus pandemic.
Back when Donald Trump was first elected president,
we had sort of this conversation where we
said who now becomes the leader of the free
world and again, the leader of the free world?
It's not a formal designation.
It's just a colloquial term.
It dates back to the Cold War.
And it more or less means who is the head
statesman of Western democratic nations.
And it's basically been the president of the
United States de facto for a long time.
But increasingly under Donald Trump and we
we discussed this three years ago, the leader
of the free world has increasingly been German
Chancellor Angela Merkel.
And again, it's not a literal desert, not
a formal title.
It's a colloquialism.
The new discussion is no longer who is the
leader of the free world.
It's not it's not Donald Trump.
That's clear.
It's more about the U.S. is rapidly losing
superpower status over our inability to properly
deal with coronavirus and our embarrassing
moral failings, which are highlighted every
single day by Donald Trump's Gong Show press
briefings.
We'll talk about that later, where he brags
about ratings and, you know, brings up religious
nuts to speak and praise him rather than presenting
the sort of sober, fact based information
that is being done not just by many of our
own governors, but if you look around the
world, you see Germany, U.S., France, U.S.,
Canada and many others, their leaders are
actually doing serious inform, informative
press conferences for their populations.
The U.S. is losing influence.
Trump was slow.
Trump was unprepared.
Trump was focused on phrases like Chinese
virus and bragging about how soon we're going
to have zero cases.
We now have around 200000, close to 200 thousand.
Governors can't get the supplies that they
need.
They're not coming to us for help.
Meaning other countries, we don't appear to
know what we're doing.
So why would anyone come to us?
Now, Trump insists everyone's coming to us.
It's not true.
And this perception that you must have American
competence if you want to properly deal with
the problem around the world.
That was a reality for a long time during
a crisis.
Other countries would say, we've got to be
involved with the U.S.
Let's get help from the U.S.
Let's get guidance that is fading very quickly
in the era of Corona virus.
Now, we've already talked about this in terms
of climate change.
The world no longer comes to the U.S. and
often doesn't even involve the U.S. when we're
dealing with climate change under Donald Trump.
They ignore us.
Trump bailed on the Paris Climate Accords.
Trump has loosened emissions law.
The EPA has now suspended pollution law.
We'll get to that later.
Regulations rather than law.
And Trump has said climate change is a hoax
created by the Chinese.
So we're out, right?
We are not a superpower when it comes to climate
change anymore.
Now, on the virus, the decline of the U.S.
as a superpower power is very, very clear.
China is sending ventilators and teams to
Italy.
They're sending masks to Belgium.
Germany has had a plan that has held down
the death rate dramatically.
Germany was early on testing.
When it comes to European countries, South
Korea mitigated the curve the most powerfully.
Remember, South Korea and the U.S. had their
first cases on the same day.
A lot of people believe South Korea had a
situation way earlier.
No, it was the same day.
They immediately developed a test.
They established fever clinics.
They established proactive family quarantine
and isolation.
We didn't.
We're behind the curve.
We're the ones who need help from other countries.
The U.S. is not the beacon that the rest of
the world is trying to emulate.
On foreign policy, we are not the beacon that
the world wants to emulate on dealing with
climate change.
And we are certainly not the beacon that the
world wants to emulate.
On Corona virus, the only emulators of the
U.S. lately are terrible.
The nationalist Indian Prime Minister Kim
Jong un, Mohammad bin SOLMAN IRDA was right.
The people now emulating the U.S. and our
leader are not the Democratic Western leaders
that we are accustomed to because they can't
look to Trump.
They would fail if they mirrored Donald Trump's
leadership or lack thereof.
The ones that do are the cartoonish morons,
right?
The Brazilian president, who insists, like
Trump, that the media is lying to them about
the.
IRRIS or whatever the case may be, we're quickly
becoming a joke and it's heartbreaking.
I take no pleasure on this.
I know people on the right keep contacting
me, saying, David, your gleeful at the death
toll, you're gleeful at the stock market crash.
No, no, no, no.
It's quite the opposite.
It's heartbreaking.
And the rapidly climbing death toll is part
of that heartbreak.
We may quickly have a situation in about three
to four months.
Where the rest of the world starts lifting
travel bans, but they have to keep the U.S.
banned because we have no idea what we're
doing or at least Donald Trump doesn't.
Mexico might all of a sudden say, hey, we
want to pay for a wall.
I'm kidding, right.
But but in the literal, literal sense, I'm
kidding.
We should be out there leading the fight against
the virus rather than falling further and
further behind with a clueless clown doing
daily press briefings where he attacks journalists,
self-congratulating and does all the things
that he's been doing.
Trump is failing because we don't have the
tools that are right for the job.
We have a president who looks to bomb things,
but you can't bomb the Corona virus.
We have a president who thinks of drones.
You can't drone the Corona virus.
You can't bribe anybody.
People need to stay home.
We need to proactively secure medical equipment.
Trump didn't.
We needed to develop a test early.
We have to use the media to get the danger
of the virus out, not to try to hide the danger
of the virus, which Donald Trump did.
Crises are Trump's kryptonite.
And this is a big one.
And it's a sad reality for the United States.
We're counting on we're relying on our governors
to get us out of this.
Some of them are doing a good job.
Some are not.
And we'll see where that goes.